Vous le croyez mort depuis des dizaines d'années
Mais depuis tout ce temps il était dans son bunker
au fin-fond de la Russie
Bon j'avoue son bunker, il ressemble beaucoup au décor de Squeezie.
Messieurs, dames, veuillez accueillir le grand, l'unique STAAALIIIIIINE !
Bonjour, je suis le petit père des peuples et j'ai ma cravate
de travers comme le président de la république française.
Aujourd'hui, je suis de retour pour terminer une guerre qui
ne s'est jamais terminée. En vrai, elle s'est terminée mais on fait genre.
Les amis, aujourd’hui, on est (pardon) compatriotes, aujourd'hui, nous sommes sur
Calm Down Stalin, un jeu
dans lequel nous allons revivre la guerre froide.
Place ta main près du bouton pour faire peur à tes ennemis.
Prend la pipe et fumes pour retirer ton stress.
Press Space or Middle Mouse Button to drop an item
D'accord .. Fait attention à ce que l’horloge n'atteigne pas midi sinon tu as perdu.
D'accord, ok, il faut juste que je mette mon doigt au-dessus du bouton et j'ai gagné
Voilà !
C'était Staline, à très vite !
Bon bah ça a l'air simple de gagner une guerre, là, dit comme ça, hein
Raccrocher au nez ou ne pas répondre, fais baisser l'intégrité de l'état, d'accord
On fûme la pipe, on met la pression, oh putain ,ok..
faut que je le mette là ?  faut que je le mette où ? faut que je le mette là près de l'horloge?
Près de oreille ok j'ai compris
Est ce qu'on peut fumer la pipe en même temps ?... Oui! c'est un bonne nouvelle
Donc on peut se déstresser tout en étant immédiatement stressé par le mec au téléphone
(applaudissement ) Splendide !
et je peux piper dans le nez? .. Tranquille
C'est Staline hein il fume la pipe comme personne
aller ça dégage
Quoi??
Voilà, c'est comme ça que les Etats-Unis ont envoyé une bombe nucléaire sur Hiroshima sans faire exprès
On fûme
On met la pression .. On fûme
On met la pression dans les pneux. Excellent !
On répond au téléphone. On se muscle un peu le bras parce qu'on est Staline et qu'il faut pas déconner.
On tape dans le téléphone parce que le mec au bout du fil nous casse les couilles
Mais NAN déjà mais le mec, c'est abusé. Il m'appelle plus que ma mère
Bon c'est vrai qu'on mène une guerre faut pas déconner. OK c'est bon il a terminé ça dégage
WHOOAAAOOO .. Putain on est passé à peu de lacher une bombe nucléaire
A cause d'un téléphone qui tombe quand même hein
Ah ça gratte beaucoup
AH ... Ah ça gratte vraiment
Ok on fait abstraction. On est un grand chef
La lampe est déverrouillée.
Quand elle se met à clignoter ça te stress donc il faut que tu la frappes pour qu'elle ne clignote plus.
Finalement comme n'importe quelle lampe IKEA
Ok c'est parti
ça clignote
TIENS!
On est bien. On est bien. On est bien. Faut gérer entre la pipe, le coup et le bouton. La pipe ...
Mais fûme putain je contrôle pas quand il fûme. Des fois, il veut pas fumer. Il m'énerve
Des fois pendant 5 secondes, il se dit : Oh, je vais arrêter de fumer la pipe pour la santé.
Quand même faut pas déconner;
Tu fûmes !!, ça te destresse
Merci à tous
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner à ma chaîne YouTube
StalineGaming
Oh putain !! Ils ont rajouté le téléphone
ça va être la guerre
Entre la lampe, le téléphone, le bouton, mon gars, et cette musique qui me stress énormement
Ok je répond
Putain mais accélère !! Et qu'est-ce qu'il ma raconte au téléphone, le gars?
Ok toujours faire attention au téléphone, c'est très pié .. C'est un .. un très gros piège
J'arrive plus à parler c'est le très gros stress. OK?!
Moi aussi, je vais me mettre à trembler comme une Staline sauf que moi j'ai rien pour me destresser.
Hein!
Tu arrêtes
ça, c'était gratuit
OH !!
Oh mon dieu mais quelle trixe
Ah Ah Ah ... INCROYABLE !!
Merci à tous
Ok, on continu
Tu as débloquer la vodka
Bois un petit verre de Vodka, réduira ton stress
Appuie sur la cloche pour le commmander
ça va ! ça me plaît ça
Alors ça mon pôte, autant dire qu'on ne va y aller de main morte
(rire) Voilà
On la boit et on l'envoie
Ok Arrête de faire des trucs stylés comme ça, Staline là, hein
Au fait, le numéro que tu m'as donné la dernière fois, C'est ta ligne (Staline) téléphonique ou pas?
Eh ouais ! Bas, il fait aussi des blagues Staline ouais
Oh non, on a pas eu le temps de se marrer avec la Vodka
L'ennemi est fort et confiant mais nous avons des outils pour miner cette confiance
Oh putain Y'a le téléphone, y'a tout.
Donc .. La pipe ...
Le doigt
Attend, on dirait le début d'un mavais film porno
(RIRE) .. Et voilà, je passe encore pour un pervers. Allez.
Allons Répondre au téléphone, qu'on passe à autre chose.
Oui Allo?
Parle à ma pipe
Tu veux tirer à travers le téléphone ou comment ça se passe
Arrête la lampe
Oui je suis là; je suis là, je suis là.
Ok
C'est bon .. La lampe .. La Vodka .. La pipe NON !
Ah je confond
Ah je m'emmmele les pinceaux
J'arrive plus à parler
Putain mais le mec, il m'appelle toutes les secondes
J'ai pas le temps de mettre mon doigt au dessus du bouton
Ok c'est bon
Attend !! ça a sonné avant même que je raccorche
Le gars, il est dans le futur. C'est pas grave. Allez, on se calme
Non
Allo, on va perdre la guerre si tu continus à m'appeler Fils de P***
Voilà ce que j'aurais dit
C'est complété
Le pistolet est déverrouillé
QUOI?? ça augmente l'intégrité de l'Etat quand tu arrives à l'utiliser et si t'y arrives pas ça la réduit.
Quand j'arrive à l'utiliser ?? Comment ça réussir à l'utiliser
On va pas tuer des gens quand même
C'est quoi cette histoire de gun
Attend tend tend tend tend !!!!! Là
Nan mais pour je passe
On efface les preuves. .. On efface, toute de suite, les preuves
Attend mais on tue des gens
On tue des gens parce qu'on est stressé, mon gars
Ce serait pas trop bien qu'on tue le mec qui arrête pas de nous appeler?
Oh putain je suis en train rêver, je me fais des idées
Oh mais attend
Attend mais on a carrément tué le serveur
OOoohh!!
Pourquoi j'ai fais ça
Bra !!
Attend .. Mais d'où je l'ai pas là
ah j'ai plus de balle
(Rire) C'est un sketch
Mais PUTAIN !!
Hop là, on tue le serveur
No !
(souffle) ça s'est fait
Voilà, voilà comment on gagne une guerre
Je suis Staline
Ah nan mais là, mec, si il mette le téléphone, le gun, la Vodka .. Je vais mourir
Putain mec, j'ai trop de trucs à faire à la seconde
Je dois tué un gars
Arrêter une lampe
Répondre au téléphone à ma putain de mère qui m'appelle en pleine guerre
C'est bon. Allez, ça dégage
WHOOAAHH !! Hop là, la serveuse, elle m'a ...
Comme j'ai eu la pression
Ma moustache, elle a dit : J'arrête, j'arrête.
Oh mon dieu ! ils ont mis la totale, quoi ?!
La Vodka, le téléphone, le bouton, on est mort
On fûmes .. le bouton .. on fûmes .. le bouton
(souffle) .. La lumière Ta gueule
Ouais, je suis là
Allo? .. Oh mon dieu mais qu'est-ce qu'on gère
NON !!
Ah j'en ai des frissons tellement je suis dég
C'est une fausse manipulation. ça arrive
Les répercutions sont pas si garve que ça
Je prend ma pepi, je la repose.
Je la prend avec cette main, je met un petit coup à la lampe, c'est gratuit, ça me fais toujours plaisir
ça , ça me fait moins plaisir
Ce niveau est super long
Heureusement qu'il ya des mecs à butter pour passer le temps
La Vodka .. Situation de crise là !!
Là, je peux jamais l'avoir celui-là
ATTENTION !!! .. WHOOAA
Allo? .. Fais vite, fais vite, fais vite. Mon bras se lève tout seul.
Ah j'entend plus, je passe sous un tunnel. Ok c'est bon, ça dégage
Oh mon dieu Oh, Oh la pression sur celui-là
Il durait une éternité
Fly unlocked ?
Fly ?? .. Depuis quand y'a des mouches dans mon bureau
Mais je pais pas une femme de ménage tous les jours pour qu'il y ai des mouches dans mon BUREAU !!
Alors on aussi déverrouillé la peinture
Voilà .. Mais elle, elle sert juste à rien
Alors je sais pas ... Putain la mouche ça va ma saouler
Je suis pas d'humeur, je suis pas d'humeur
Casses-toi . Oh la p*** elle reste juste à côté du bouton
Pour que je fasse une fausse manip'
Dégage ! Putain je te ferais executer sur la place publique putain de mouche
Dégaaage!! Putain deuxième jour. Mon dieu, est-ce qu'on va gagner cette guerre un jour?
Je commence à faiblir. Oh bordel, ils ont tous mis
Oh ça m'a fait du bien.
Elle fait même pas un bruit de mouche, elle fait un bruit d'alien.Tu vois je suis sûre, c'est une infiltrée, elle-aussi en vrai
C'est le Américains, ils ont réussi à transformer des humains en mouche et les ont envoyé pour m'espionner
Putain les enculers, je le savais. Dégaaaaage !!
D'accord donc la mouche vient de voler le pistolet je sais pas si vous avez vu. C'est quand même scandaleux. Hein
Allo ?
C'est quand tu m'appelles pour me dire qu'on a gagné le guerre. Oh la p***
Oh la p***, tiens le téléphone dans ta gueule
Putain mais il n'arrête jamais là ! C'est la 7ème fois
Tu arrêtes Michel sinon on va finir par nous cramer
Oh oui! C'est bon.
Putain ..  Les niveaux sont de plus en plus long
Je transpire de plus en plus
ça me gratte de plus en plus
Plus rien ne vas putain!
J'arrive même plus à viser avec une arme alors que c'est ma spécialité
Ok on continu, on est chaud
(DING) OH !
Oh ça c'est le réveil qui m'indique que ma journée est terminé putain
Ooh aïe! Oh bas oui,  la guerre attendra demain mon enculer, hein
C'était le petit père de peuples
Là, je devient le petit client des bars des peuples
Allez, à très vite
Staline étant en CDI 35 heures, il venait de terminer sa journée.
Il alla alors se bourrer la gueule au bar du coin sans penser à la guerre
Comment tout cela va-t-il se terminer?
La mouche va-t-elle s'en aller?
Le FDP qui n'arrête pas d'appeler va-t-il crever dans d'atroces souffrances
IKEA, vont-ils lui envoyer une lampe qui fonctionne correctement ?
Le serveur amènera-t-il plus d'un chouteur, à la fois.
Tant de questions restent sans réponse
A très vite